um you know these are things that are so
natural
um that happen to most people
um and why not kind of
share in our experiences uh make it a
little easier for everyone take away the
Mystique you know so you're not
wondering in my normals it's supposed to
be happening is everybody else going
through this you know we can just all
like tell it like it is
um maybe have some laughs have a little
you know uh relief and
um otherwise you know this like all
these crazy stories wind up coming yeah
out about our bodies that
um is just we could just bypass that all
together
and embrace what it is to be a human and
a and a person just the beauty of
growing up